you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 7
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this game Carlson takes
a three and a half to two and a half
lead and Carlsen with the white pieces
in this one he opens with E 4 he's yet
to deviate playing with the white pieces
all games he 4 it is and we follow game
2 in this one once again seeing the Roy
Lopez Berlin defense in game two it was
d3 is the follow-up however this time
around it's castles 94 and we go into
this line very common true Berlin
defense Queens no longer around just
like in game 6 they're quick to be
exchanged and well what's the quick
summary here black on Castle black with
the deficient Queen side structure but
is compensated with the bishop pair
white having this healthy 4 versus 3
majority looks to one day set in motion
h3 is a step in that direction not
wanting to play g4 right away this would
be highly committal and well it cannot
be maintained the light-square control
be struck out with h 5 h 3 first making
the less committal move first and only
then when more development has been made
in the position this pond could think
about playing up to G form but for now
it's just baby step approach h3 it is
king e Knight c3 h5 restricts g4 and
there's another ID in mind with it
that'll soon be revealed some more
development first white occupying the
only open file and on Bishop e6 Knight
g5 decided additional idea rook h6
defending the bishop on Knight takes
Bishop rook takes in this pawn structure
stays as is it stays together a group of
3 we don't have that instead its g3 if
g3 isn't played instead a3 just making
it passing a move if g3 isn't played at
this point notice how black and play h4
and it's not so easy to see how these
pawns get rolling one day
right any g4 move we have capture and
this structure is really messy unhealthy
and I think you're going to actually
lose some material at some stage so g3
does not allow this advance anymore on
h4 there would be g4 and this night is
actually in some serious trouble g3 is
also doing what more well King wants to
play up be a bit more essential and
contribute it's making way for small
King improvement
what follows as Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes Bishop rook g6 very active
opposed for the rook very artificial way
of getting the rook active but it's very
active hitting the bishop most directly
placing this pawn indirectly in a pin he
goes nowhere white anchors that Bishop
there and something needs to be done
about this guy for as long as he's on
this diagonal how exactly does this rook
get activated in order for white to get
this piece working he needs to give
something up there is a cost here with
this next move f6 the cost is what
exactly well after this exchange notice
how these ponds they were together at
this point here a nice group of three
but he to break the coordination on this
d8 square f6 does that but now these
pawns are split but black has something
in mind Bishop f4 hits the pond but
notice how this pawn is now directly in
a pin which means what exactly well
there goes your age pond and one might
think white would return the favor pick
a pond right back up but just like in
game 2 those of you that have been
falling following this World Chess
Championship match in game 2 there was
an instance where Carlsen could have
picked up a pond but instead focused
more on the centralization of pieces and
more pressing issues in this case there
is a more pressing issue and that is to
keep the knight out of the f3 square if
white is to pick up that pond notice how
Knight f3
can be on board and on kingi too we
could have this little back and forth
and if white is really wanting to avoid
that type of represent repetition
he'd have to throw his king in the
corner not the ideal environment in this
endgame position so the way to fix that
is to recognize he is insignificant it's
more important here is to keep the
knight out of f3 f3 is played rook is
there to defend and there's now a new
pocket for the King to move towards the
center on f2 and when he plays there a
punch would be thrown at the knight rook
to d8 King f2 the night is now hit rook
takes Knight takes this this pond could
be picked up and is in the game in short
order this Knight is looking to
reposition to the e3 square Knight f5
rook h1 giving up a 2 but getting the H
pawn in return as it stands right now
after Bishop e6 white is the site who's
down upon but is compensated by the fact
that his rook is much more active of the
two certainly looking to get to the
seventh rank pressure on the knight this
rook it is a half-open file this one
here but it's a well-defended pawn on G
3 Bishop and King are conveniently
defending and this pawn here could be
picked up it would seem at any moment
although in the game he goes nowhere
this pawn lives
what exactly does black come up with
after g4 the knight has to make a
decision choosing d6
and on this very active post by the rook
we now have Knight f7 nice
reorganization of the pieces the bishops
there to defend the knight and the
Knights also there to watch out for
ensuing checks on h8 can't really make
much further progress with the rook on
h7
what follows is 93 King d8 now this
Bishop is the only one around to watch
out for the night he's there to defend
the pond but now he's had
has two jobs here he could only I should
stay to like this after night f5 the
move played in the game he cannot take
the night so when black plays here he's
defending the pun but has to now deal
with the night residing on this f5
square
he's immune from capture Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes Bishop now your rook
and Knight our hit and white would be
winning so he has to work black has to
work around this pesky Knight so what
comes up next we have c5 initially I
thought it's there to take out 1 square
by the knight that's true an additional
idea behind that is to make a quick
shift with the black King by way of d7
and then c5 and I I say a quick shift
because our quick reposition because
when you play to d7 you're now you would
now be in a pin right and you don't want
to stay in a pin you don't want to go
into a self pin for long so if you're
going to play to d7 I thought one of the
ideas was then to be able to make use of
this newly created home on c6 so that c5
advance in other words guards d4 most
directly but now has a new pocket
available for the King to go to where
he'd be more central ok as a follow up
we have Knight g3 he looks to reposition
by way of e4 or h5 this is the more
appealing of the two being in the center
where he hits at c5 which is currently
unprotected and keeps pressure on the f6
pawn following up we have 95 and a lot
of time was spent on this move now what
exactly was black having to calculate
when he plays Knight to e5 that will
soon be revealed what we have as a
follow up is rook h8 check rook g8
Bishop takes Knight notice on rook takes
rook there's Bishop takes pawn the rook
will be one back white is up a piece and
winning and after pawn takes pawn
we have rook h5 what
happening with this pawn on e5 one
variation I would like to point out is
well one that comes to this very
position but with the rook still on g6
or in other words this one right here
this is the first opportunity where Y
can go ahead and grab that night but
he's inserting this check for a
particular reason notice how if white
meets this move the move played in the
game ninety five with Bishop takes
Knight
look how things are a bit different with
the rook being on g6 after rook h5 there
is this move Bishop to eight two seems a
bit odd but he's looking to get at this
c2 pond and it's clearing the way for
this rook to play along the sixth ring
to play over to b6 on rook takes e
there's rook v6 how do you defend
against b2 b3 is met with c4 this
structure is being broken down and the
end result of all this is what exactly
well the black rook is getting active
and as soon as this b pond is no longer
around this guy the a7 pond is past past
rook pawn this knight cringes at the
fact are at the idea of trying to stop a
past rook pawn very difficult to
coordinate a knight in a way to stop
that past rope on the short story here
is that black would get activity in this
variation right here where white could
one day in other words have these two
connected past pawns but black will be
able to get a passed pawn himself and
keep in mind black is the one who has a
superior minor piece one that will be
there to watch over these pawns from
advancing so easily to these queening
squares and he is also around to
influence well both sides of the board
this pawn again would remain passed in
this variation of sighting with the rook
coming over on the sixth rank compare
this with the rook check move first
after rook check rook g8
notice after Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes rook h5 this idea this earlier
shown idea of Bishop a2 trying to get
the rook over to b6 well the rook isn't
on g6 you can't make use of that b6
square anymore and this is very
difficult right you're not going to have
as quick a counter play in other words
against these Queen side pawns so what
exactly is black going to come up with
here very very important decision at
this moment right here on book FA if
look to f8 is played here rook takes
pawn would be met with Bishop takes
Bishop but white simply proves the King
position this is what what would do
improve the King position avoid this
capture and now this is back on and on
Bishop d5 looking to meet rook takes
pawn with rook takes pawn
well once again white would address this
threat against f3 with 94 and black has
locked into this variation right here it
is the only active plan that y can move
forward with and as Carlsen stated in
the game or excuse me during the press
conference he referenced that this may
be a holdable draw for black but it is a
very narrow path to a draw very easy to
go wrong from this position on b6
there's rook c3 still keeping an eye on
the pun and one of these squares making
it more difficult for this pawn to Queen
meanwhile these guys are very very fast
not a direction that black went in so
what did black come up with Bishop takes
g4 giving up the piece and trying to
play this position out where what do we
have 4 vs. 2 white also has this minor
piece the main plan here for black is to
somehow exchange off these two pawns and
arrive at a position where it is just
these highlighted pieces on board rook
and Knight the versus rook position
which is a theoretical drop how will
black be able to manage that
if at all let's see what follows be 694
a lot of maneuvering goes on in this
ending in fact we run well beyond a 100
moves in this game b3 is played
providing a pocket for the King he
quickly arrives there a six keeps a
close eye on b5 you'll want to be on the
black side very cautious about moving
your pawns not wanting to give up so
many squares this is however a very
purposeful move I want to keep that
Knight out of there rookie for the black
rook kicks the King all the way to B -
he's there tucked in nicely with this
pawn structure how will light make
progress though the rook is there
watching over the King I can't kick the
King back so easily Knight d1 this is
one attempt that white has it's also
worth noting that having the rooks off
the board will make life easier for the
white side it's trading the pieces is
not necessarily making the draw make is
not making holding the draw any easier
for the black side in fact this is the
last piece that black has that can buy
some time and shuffle back and forth
without a one day maybe arriving at a
position where black has to concede some
ground to ruin his King position in some
way or make a committal pawn move
there's always these rook advances or
rook shuffling type of ideas that black
can go forward with black will not be so
quick to give up his only piece that
could have you know several Tempe in
hand so to speak
so the rooks shall remain on board in
this one black is wise to keep the rooks
on board rook h6 rook e 7 this is what
white would really like to have happen a
knight on d5 and well the rook on the
seventh rank or in other words white
would really like to converge
c7 square but black is a pain keeping
the night honest not allowing this idea
of getting the pawn up to c4 and then
Knight to d5 again this is one of the
ideas to get the knight in to d5 to
apply pressure to coordinate pressure on
c7 rook h2 interferes with that you
cannot move the pawn up to c4 so easily
rookie six King goes back and now King
c3 what's being threatened now Knight d5
and then rookie 7 black is interfering
with that notice how on Knight d5 right
now there would be rook to d4 if I'm to
take it just one step back right here
suppose after King B seven night here
what would you do on the black side at
this moment there's two ways to bring
that nice position into question and
which way is best if you go to h5
there's simply c4 and this is not long
off from happening you can stop that
pressure with rook here but once again
white is welcome to a rook exchange and
that is necessary at this point white
would be winning this so the way to
approach this position is to know that
if the knight does arrive on d5 right
now this is what black would do rook to
d2 you cannot play c4 this is a legal
move that's how black would follow this
is how black would put into question the
Knights position on d5 to attack him by
way of d2 not h5 so we have as a follow
up King c3 getting ready for this idea
but again rook age for an ID 5 there
would be root D for the King try
something else a little shuffle right
there Knight d5 rook d2 is tried Knight
f6 looking for something else eventually
white comes up with the following plan
with a lot of shuffling first eventually
there we go finally we have some action
something has changed with the structure
pawn is on c4
white was not able to going a handful
moves back white was not able to as we
just saw to get a knight on d5 and then
anchor him there on c4 he wasn't able to
accomplish that so easily so what white
just tried here is to simply switch the
move order instead of trying to get the
knight on d5 and then support him well
first he's going to put that support
point out there and then look to get the
knight in to d5 so some progress clearly
being made here the knight is looking
for what exactly and d5 and black is not
able to just keep the structure as is at
this point if he just kind of goes back
and forth it's a very key move here
rook h5 basically keeping a close eye on
this pond because one of the ideas that
black has is to shift up his King and
his King and pawns by way of b5 c6 and
King to b6 these three pieces and pawns
the King c7 and b6 will all be shifted
up one Square soon enough in order to
combat this idea of the knight getting
into d5 and the rook getting to e7
notice how going back and forth does
black very little because at the end of
the day this is going to happen the
knight will play here and the rook will
play here White has beautiful
coordination King defends the pawn all
of these guys are glued together as well
as the rook so in order to combat that
idea black is once again staying on this
fifth rank lending support to this pond
which is soon to be weakened notice with
any pawn move there is some weakness
that is left behind and surely with b5
it's the c5 squared that would be
weakened black anticipates this in
pressure against that point at some
stage as soon as b5 is played so he's
staying here in other words soon we'll
have black push up right now and this
move 61 Knight c3 c6
everything is getting shifted up just a
little bit on the black side and now
white goes in for this rookie 7 King B
697 the King is getting pushed forward
is this going down a very dangerous path
or what for the black King well maybe
not so much so after King before notice
he's there to put pressure on these puns
and what is the idea still to eliminate
these two pawns on the white side what
is white going to come up with after
rookie for this certainly interferes
with King to b4 if King b4 is played
right now there's pawn takes and that's
a discovered check King takes is
necessary and white is winning this
position there's not going to be a way
to exchange off these puns for the the
only remaining white pawn the rook is
they're watching over these squares a 4
and C 4 and the knight is not long off
from helping out with that as well the
King is also conveniently placed to
watch over that B pond so King before is
not a good choice in other words rook g2
king c1 rook g1 King D - unlike game 6
King D - is not a mistake those of you
following this patch game 6 King D - was
a big deal it was a blunder was a
mistake and that came not here rook G -
king e1 this is the only way to really
try and stop these checks but notice how
the king is drifting further away from
being in a position to help out with
defense of these guys over here the B
and C pawns one cute move here is this
right here instead of king e1 supposed
king c3 this would have been interesting
on King c3 there is this cute move B for
King D 3 the only move and now rook D -
what a cool finish that would be you got
to take the rook if you don't take the
rook you're losing and if you do take
the rook you must take the rook at this
point
is this a stalemate no black pawns can
move and the King can't move all these
squares are covered that would have been
a cool stalemate certainly white was
aware of that not going to see three
here kingi one instead and now black
goes for it
what I mean by that well there has been
some I should say black has been
hesitant to give up this central pawn to
split his own pawns like this but he
goes for it grabbing on c4 and C's away
to force white into a passive position
so while these pawns are split notice
how the White King is far away and this
will play a great role after rook g3
applies pressure to b3 not so many
options here and they take c5 that's
there to defend King to b5 what's
threatened right now is rook takes pawn
for example and I can move towards this
pawn over here on King d2 there would be
rook takes b3 and black is successful
with eliminating that last pot and I
takes rook King takes rook so that's the
threat here can't just make a King move
so what's tried is rook c1 you only try
playing here and you're you're in
trouble
rook g1 there goes your rook there goes
your knight
that wouldn't be good so it's rook c2
and now a five preparing to one day play
a four if this Knight is not around to
watch over a four there would be a four
and finally black would have eliminated
this remaining pun still what black is
shooting for here King f2 rook h3 rook
c1 this was a threat rook c1 gets out of
that idea King bee for more pressure
here it's a restricted position a very
active position by black
it's very interesting how that came
about light was the one trying to come
up with some play here but that black
King got very very active Knight is tied
down to the pawn rook is tied down to
the defense of the night King e2 and now
rook c3 there really wasn't much more
that you could do on the white side he's
too far away he's not there in time to
stop this idea of roaches see three rook
c3 is on board and unrep takes rook
there's King tags this is a dead drawn
position what do you do here if you move
the knight you drop the pawn something
else King III King before king d4
defends the knight king b5 if you move
the king you drop your knight
if you move your knight the King plays
here you got to go back and forth this
would be a draw here instead what is
tried is 93 King takes pawn and this is
certainly going to turn out to be a draw
there was some try here just some
dancing around eventually these pawns
I'll get picked up we don't quite get to
see some type of a 50 move rule or
anything like that it becomes a draw
much sooner but they play it out a
little bit maybe Carlsen just out of
momentum is going on for this it's
certainly a draw with the 30 second
increment having already been
implemented by move 16 these players are
gaining 30 seconds per move and it's
just goes on for a little bit longer
eventually that last pun is picked up we
go all the way to what move exactly we
reach in this game move 122 and this one
eventually the rooks by karlsen's
choosing here he goes in for a rook
exchange basically saying okay you
defended well and let's move on to game
8 that's the last move of this game
again it went 122 moves it's a draw they
shook hands at this point and we move on
to game 8 this game took six and a half
hours you could probably hear to my
voice it's
a bit worn but I'm going to continue to
do this I'm enjoying it and I hope you
are as well so we'll see what happens in
game eight which happens tomorrow right
now as it stands it is four points to
cut for Carlson and three points for a
nun it is a race to six and a half and
we'll see who gets there first so that's
all for this video as always I hope you
got something out of it take care bye
you